Un bilan provisoire de 227 morts
qui risquent de s'alourdir.
- Samedi matin.
8h30, heure locale.
Haiti tremble. Un séisme
de magnitude 7,2 se produit
tout près de la ville
de Saint-Louis-du-Sud
au sud-ouest de la Capitale
Port-au-Prince.
Des hôtels, des églises,
des maisons se sont effondrés
ravivant les pires souvenirs
du tremblement de terre
de 2010 qui a fait plus
de 200 000 morts et
des milliers de sans-abris.
Une alerte au Tsunamie
est déclenchée provoquant
la panique. Les haïtiens
courent pour se réfugier
sur les montagnes.
Le gouvernement a décrété
l'état d'urgence pour un mois.
ARIEL HENRY,
Premier ministre haïtien
- Le gouvernement a décidé
ce matin de décréter l'état
d'urgence pour un mois.
Le premier ministre appelle
la population à demeurer
solidaire et d'éviter
la panique.
Le directeur de la protection
civile fait état de centaines
de morts dont l'ancien sénateur
Gabriel Fortuné.
Les hôpitaux reçoivent
les premiers blessés,
ils débordent.
STÉPHAN ODÉNAT, Dir. médical,
Centre médical Gaétan Bouchard
- Oui, on est débordé
effectivement avec les blessés,
mais aussi beaucoup
de traumatisés,
surtout les enfants.
Les médecins crient à l'aide
pour des renforts,
il manque d'équipement.
- Comme chez nous, on a encore
quelques paquets de gaz
on a quelques solutés,
mais je pense que si on reçoit
autant de cas ce matin, dans
les prochaines heures, nous
n'aurons plus de ressources.
L'approvisionnement sera
difficile : des routes sont
sectionnées et des bandes
criminelles les dominent.
EMILIE NICOLAS, Antropologue
et Chroniqueuse, Le Devoir
- Il y a eu une demande de
trêve. Techniquement,
les secours devraient pouvoir
se déplacer, mais même
l'accès donc au sud
à partir de la capitale pourrait
être compliqué dans les derniers
jours s'il n'y a pas
une collaboration
des gangs armés.
- Le mauvais sort semble
s'acharner sur la perle
des Antilles.
Les cicatrices du tremblement
de terre de 2010 étaient encore
bien visibles quand l'ouragan
Matthews a frappé durement
l'ouest de l'île en 2016.
Et le gouvernement du pays
est à la dérive à la suite
de la mort, cet été,
de son président Jovenel Moise,
froidement assassiné
par un escadron armé.
C'est le premier ministre
Ariel Henry qui est à la tête
du pays dont l'autorité
est contestée.
RAYMOND LAURENT, journaliste
et animateur à CKUT
- L'état est démissionnaire.
Il n'y a pas de vie en Haiti.
il n'y a pas de vie, les gens
ne peuvent pas sortir, ne
peuvent pas traverser le sud
avec les gang de rue,
ce n'est pas normal.
- Un pays à genoux dont
la résilience semble
sans bornes.
Ici M